incoming transmission
how's it going gamers it's now been
a week since my reverse face reveal
there's a lot of mixed reactions out
there so let's check
it out i was told people are very upset
which they should can a sarcastic face
show in this
[Laughter]
they should be
faces backlash from the v tuber
community
oh god not the vtuber community
okay let's check this out is this a pew
news the most popular
individual youtube creator oh that's me
it's not it's not but okay thank you it
sparked controversy
you'd think if something sparked
controversy there would be
some notice of of it in my videos like
click on my latest video
wow what a controversy everyone is just
talking about this can you believe this
ah who uploaded these you're getting
boring
all right they brought up pokemon all
right here we go guess who's canceled
pewdiepie [ __ ] i didn't even know how
did i miss this
no one handed me a letter of resignation
i love being canceled and not knowing
about it
the [ __ ] is this some expressed concern
over a person using a face filter okay
youtuber community is saying do you
really want edgy audience alongside
all the white supremacists in the
audience wait youtubers are white
supremacists
okay so this was my first youtuber
persona
i spent a great deal on it let's see
what people are saying
it's 100 naive to think you know what
is it even worth reading is there a
point of doing this
i feel like i've gone through this some
dumbass makes opinion online
some dumbass that don't even show their
own face on like
what's the point but anyway it's 100
names to think of pewdiepie being a
youtuber it's good thing for
indie v tubers okay indeed youtubers
don't show my facetime i want it to be
hidden at all times
sure there's more exposure but do you
really want that edgy audience alongside
all the white supremacists in the
audience
regardless what are they talking about
you guys
are you guys so much of white
supremacists okay good to know
won't engage in further discourse about
pewdiepie himself
aloha they're right i'm not even gonna
get started with my discourse
they have a whole google doc i've done
enough of that already in my life
i'm living rent-free he's a white
supremacist and endorsing him is an
endorsement of what is
there is no debate
there is no other opinion allowed if i
see anybody
being hyped at the advice of youtube
especially this point in time with all
the discourse
i know a word that isn't commonly used
so i use it all the time
i am 12. and controversy that happened
over the years i won't hesitate to block
and let others know
that you're excited about a white
supremacist
amazing there's no debate guys so don't
even bother
pewdiepie becoming a youtuber [ __ ]
scares me yeah right
you should be scared because i'm the
biggest youtuber out there
y'all indie [ __ ] i'm a
mainstream bad [ __ ] coming to push
all of you out i'm the top dog the tiger
i'mma eat you
ooh can we do vampire teeth on this
youtuber avatar that'd be sick
pewdiepie becoming veto birthing scares
me please for the love of god me to
push him the [ __ ] out of it like i would
leave
the more you push the more i want to be
part of this this is amazing
hello i've heard pewdiepie is becoming a
youtuber
if you support this follow him or
consume his content
please unfollow me i do not want you
here
okay fair enough oh i was trending
oh as i said probably a bad thing
overall especially for lgbtq plus v2
how what the [ __ ] did i do
wait why do people think it's a white
supremacist okay fair question i would
like to know
he's not he's actually a girl okay
just google i love that
source uh google if you google i'm sure
flight our theory will
will come up as well all right there's
some people defending me in the comments
i appreciate you
this is great i need to figure out more
ways to piss off idiots
this is my new hobby
i was just gonna have the v tuber thing
for like a couple days
all right here we go there's more to be
fair there's just a few people saying
this right
i don't think this is like yeah hey look
it's the same idiot
no matter what you're always gonna have
dumb people
online this is this is a problem with
the internet in general
people throwing their opinions out there
your opinion don't matter
it really does i know it's shocking
honestly the only the one thing i was
super worried about was
this v tuber thing is going to be
adopted by racist and the novelty won't
be pure anymore
the novelty
can you imagine a bunch of racists just
doing people and what does that have to
do with me
[ __ ] limited 2017 and even then it
was a stretch
all right so there's some people saying
positive things i appreciate
we are also celebrating terry crews
acknowledging us
yeah that's big i was so stoked about
that
when tara cruz acknowledged me as a
vtuber i was like
i was livid man i could have a whole
discourse about it
i could discourse left them right it's a
v2 burger inch account
nice i saw some people saying like
pewdiepie is a millionaire
why does he bother spending money i
think this is on my own reddit yeah
i don't [ __ ] i don't know where why do
you spend a bunch of money on a proper v
tuber
cause i it's a joke why wouldn't
i'm doing it as a joke
can you believe this it's called epic
trolling yeah
it's funny even my own fans kind of had
some dumb opinions about it
i can understand i went on a break and
then surprise i am also not showing my
face
like yeah okay kind of annoying get that
but the people going like why does he
not spend proper money on one
because i don't care why the [ __ ] should
i can you
what was wrong with my face huh is there
something wrong with these
i was so proud of this oh and i saw
people saying that my
my original one looked like ellen
degeneres and that just hurt
because i don't look like her at all
there you go that is not ellen degeneres
okay why is everyone making such a deal
of pewdiepie becoming veto
why the heck shouldn't he anyone can be
a youtuber what anyone can install a
simple program on their computer
no no only i can do that didn't they
give a pokemon of us a [ __ ] too
it's beautiful i love it she didn't
respond sad
oh that's another thing people said that
uh
people are just cashing in on a trend
first of all it's so dumb
people think this where's the money
where's the youtuber money
huh where's the beat over money i was
promised
this is [ __ ] hey if anything i just
pissed off brands because
i was supposed to do brand deals and
they're like well you need to show your
face i'm like no i'm a youtuber now
if anything i lose money from this
actual money
not [ __ ] v tuber money whatever the
[ __ ] that is
you are catching another trend you're
already famous
and have shown your face right now we
work our hearts out
oh what victims there are right there
those poor there's poor people i
truly feel for them try to bandwagon and
capitalize on it all you want but e
thoughts will never
be better than the tubers yeah man
trying to capitalize
alright guys who do we piss off next
what
this is so much fun i am so bored about
of people's petty drama and [ __ ] but
this was actually funny
why is it always receives backlash and
it's like
four or five people that come out with a
dumbest opinion that no one agrees with
they're facing backlash no just dumb
people exist
in general this is why i i say i said it
before and i say it again the internet
was a mistake people aren't meant
supposed to have a voice
especially really dumb people you did it
twitter
you did it it is fun to laugh at though
it's just sometimes
i think it gets a bit redundant because
it's just the same thing all over again
but yeah people are pissed off
rightfully so
and i decided it's time for me to come
clean
and actually make a face reveal because
i don't want to upset
the v tuber community any longer
surprise everyone are you surprised this
is how i look like
sister fister see you tomorrow bet you
don't have this blue
bet you don't have this green i bet you
don't have the biggest ball the world
has seen
[Music]
life i got the best life it's easy to
see and 100 million people agree
because i'm mine all day i'm mine all
night